So let me just explain to you why this is called Naive Bayes.
What we've done is we've said there's unknown concepts.
These are our target labels.
Let's call them label A and label B.
And you don't get to see them.
They're hidden.
As is always the case in, in supervised learning.
And what you're going to see instead.
are things that they do.
Like words they use.
If they use them with exactly the same probability you
could never figure out what it is.
If they use it with different probabilities and they might use one of them or
a 100 or a 1,000.
But every word that you see like this one over here gives you
evidence as to whether it was person A or person B.
And what you do is, you just multiply all the evidences for every word you see.
And it's a big product.
You do this for person A and for person B.
And you multiply in the prior and when this product comes out,
it gives you the ratio of whether you believe it's person A or person B.
That is called Naive Bayes.
It let's you identify from a text source whether this label is more likely or
this label is more likely.
And you can do this with people, with news sources, you can
ask the question was the text written by Shakespeare or by somebody else.
It's a very powerful tool, that's widely used all across machine learning.
And the reason why it's called Naive
is because it ignores one thing, and you tell me which one it is?
All the individual words in the message,
the order of your words inside a message,.
Or the length of the message.
Which one is being plainly ignored here?